hi I'm Sam and I'm Asian now if you're
Asian like me you might have heard of
spam no not that
spit I'm talking about
no one really ever think I was
attractive and all the people that I
thought looked super attractive on
television they look nothing like me so
I basically grew up never talking to
girls sorry sorry this is funny they
look nothing like me yeah cause you're a
dude
that threw me off I know what you meant
now that was normal in middle school and
that was tolerated in high school but
now I'm a grown college student and I've
never been on a date in my life in order
to ask out 100 girls I need to find a
hundred girls Beggars can't be choosers
so I don't care what they're like as
long as they're 18 and up so what's a
good place to find girls 18 and up a
college we're going back to college I
like that attitude Beggars can't be
choosers absolutely a lot of you
[ __ ] watching at home got some
stupid ass standards uh lower them
[ __ ] because you're ugly and you're
not getting no [ __ ] and it's probably
because you as a dude oftentimes got too
high of a standard
shout outs to him he's starting off on
the right foot would you go on a date
with me no why I'm alive let's try that
again would you go on a date with me
um well uh we're kind of um
yeah they were together so that [ __ ] up
all right listen whatever you guys say
to get out of projecting somebody I
guess
I don't know you so no I can't just be
like all right let's like you know go
out
is there anything I could do to convince
you otherwise if you can show me
show me in my Dimension you're a strong
person let's go find number six
realistically know because I'm
interested is there anything I can do to
convince you otherwise maybe like give
me like a million dollars would you go
on a date with me
[Music]
yeah I mean you seem very
straightforward and I'd be down to go
and date with you better and to make
things worse he could have just walked
away but you know what he did he
immediately asked out the girl sitting
right next to her this guy's an idiot
would you go on a date with me yes I
like how you approached me well I feel
this [ __ ] went would you like to
go on a date with me yes good
would you like to go on a date with me
and she went oh I like that approach the
one where you asked my friend out first
before me because you thought I guess
maybe she was cuter yeah I like that
whatever works worked I guess hey
but I'll talk about that later can I
double date y'all okay another two cars
you guys are too kind today you guys are
way too
would you go on a date with me yes
here's your chance Sam you've learned
from your mistakes with girls eight and
nine now's your chance to schedule a
really big what if I didn't have a
boyfriend I'd go on a date with you
all right I'm gonna let this play I mean
let's play today it's a no I'm not in a
mental state right now I feel like I
feel like talked first and
[Music]
I have a girlfriend would you go on a
date with me
[Music]
what about somewhere in UCSD would you
say yes if I said somewhere in UCSD yeah
why not I usually like to like talk to
people before I go on a date with them
you're talking to me now is this a yes
or no no well your mom this is my
boyfriend so did you go on a date with
me uh sure yeah why not yes no no I
don't really know you but that's how
good a date is what what kind of date
would you want to go on
[Music]
okay I'm down
I trust people the guys who like
approach approach girls
I feel like there's a red flag I've had
a red flag with any guy who's ever done
that you don't know [ __ ] about [ __ ] my
girl
you do not know I've said guys who
approach girls is a red flag I mean it
in her fence
is she looking for a relationship I
could see why because the only dudes you
approach right now are [ __ ] who do a
lot of approaching and dudes who do a
lot of approach ain't probably gonna
settle down anytime soon so she's the
one that's going to do the protein
that's not the point the point is dudes
who are approaching it right now are
probably good news you're just going to
[ __ ] around
there's nothing to do on this and they
go like let me get a relationship no uh
they're gonna go through some [ __ ] okay
every dude I know who did the pickup
stuff any exactly relationship Material
off the top like you can approach but
not like out of the blue it's like more
of like a like you're waiting in line
you're like oh like have you tried this
oh well have you tried this
would you go on a date with me I have a
girlfriend I'm talking to someone I'm
pretty busy I have a boyfriend boyfriend
this guy's actually my boyfriend so
if I was single I might be tempted but
yeah
I don't know you at all I'm too
emotionally attached to fictional
characters right now would you go on a
date with me I don't know I don't say no
to that question I don't have the best
set of personal safety which probably
isn't something I should be saying on
the internet I have a boyfriend I'm kind
of talking to someone right now I'm not
interested in dating right now would you
go on a date with me
yes why why why do I I don't believe
that yes well okay we'll talk about that
afterwards okay what are you talking all
about that boyfriend boyfriend no
because I also have a boyfriend he can
also come
um I mean he might like he's pretty
social yeah because I don't live here
maybe we could like hang out a little
before like going on a date also would
you want to hang out
yeah sure but like the thing is I have a
boyfriend well would you look at that
we've uh reached the halfway point
remember that study that said like most
people under the age of 25 never had a
relationship but you see this video and
all of a sudden oh everybody's got
boyfriends
funny how that works ain't it what'd
y'all think you think this study's lied
or you think they lied
I'm not mad at him I understand why
women say they got boyfriends it's the
easiest way to reject somebody is dudes
tend to walk away when they hear that
right because if a woman just flat out
says no dudes tend to be like how can I
change your mind right where should you
have a boyfriend dudes tend to walk away
I understand why they do I don't know
about you guys but wallets have always
been an issue for me that's where
today's sponsor extra comes into play
what I love about this wallet the design
the fact that it's efficient uh I stick
all the cards that I need inside here
and then if at any point I want to pull
them out I only need to sift through my
thing I just like this poop and then I
know which card it is I just pull out
the car real Sleek push it back in boom
simple and it doesn't fall out as you
can see right here doesn't matter how
much I shake honestly it feels like one
of them Batman toys is that cool extra
also has some cool accessories that
involve using an app on your phone you
can activate this tracker and the
tracker stays with it so when you're
traveling this could be a godsend and
there's many times this kind of
Technology would have saved Myers so
amazing design amazing functionality at
amazing prices and what's more if you
follow the link in the description
section below right now they got a good
old Christmas sale going so you can get
up to 40 percent off that's right you
can save some money you feel me get
yourself one of these and treat yourself
there's no reason why I need to go with
these big bulky wallets with or maybe if
it's not for you you know maybe it's a
special man you know in your life ladies
if you guys are thinking of what to get
your man yeah I mean for this holiday
season
this is it every dude I've shown it to
so far is like I gotta get me one of
those so don't hesitate guys use a link
in the description below and get
yourself one too would you go on a date
with me like a little people earlier
that's it I don't want a guy who's for
the streets I have a boyfriend yeah
probably a date is just today then I
think my coffee is like something
because say yes to anyone too yeah I
mean you seem fine dang girl I think
you're fine too
that sounded so immigranty
but it was actually a pretty good job I
think that's probably the funniest thing
you said this whole time yeah yeah damn
girl I think you're fine too yeah yeah
yeah yeah it was a little bit ratchet
but I liked that that was good that was
good bro I mean I feel like I'd have to
get to know you first yeah I don't know
you seem like a nice person and you have
a cool personality you just approached
me and then this girl gives me Adam Adam
family's lives yes who am I thinking of
uh that's Tuesday evening not quite
Wednesday
if I'm not gonna get the second one do
you want me to be really honest yeah go
for it you're not like type what is your
type uh
tall uh am I not tall
you you cut her out she's about to say
tall
dark and handsome
can you guess which of those she doesn't
think you are
good
we're all in agreement
okay maybe I can give you like half a
date what the hell I gave up men for
lunch so unfortunately no what the
heaven and a long distance
I would definitely consider one to ten I
think you're a nine and I'm the one you
need oh that's good see yeah that would
probably I would probably
if it works
I mean I thought it worked at that age
that could work I would definitely be
like I'm sure yeah all right where are
we going
um I'm so sorry I got I got a shawty on
the side but yeah what yeah what campus
is that because it's got the most amount
of lesbians I've ever seen in my life
yeah that's a lot of bro this look like
a whole ass Pride Parade the way these
girls are always into other women God
damn I'm engaged
is there anything I can do to change
I prefer being single I don't really
have time for boys right now I have
never been on a date before you don't
want me to be the first one I'm a
boyfriend I just got out of a really
really my boyfriend
right here right there would you go on a
date with me
sure sure
okay so I'm uh actually running out of
time so let's Breeze through the rest of
these there were a couple more no's I am
um into women I I'm also into women God
damn I don't know what it's about Parks
but if you find a woman in the park the
odds of her being a lesbian just go up
it's a campus that's a park to me on the
camera yeah there's grass that's a park
that's how it works and if you see him
on the grass
they might be lesbian why do you think
these Lesbos like
picnic so much
because they get to eat out
yes 30 second conversation we had before
this you're funny and you can like
actually hold a conversation a lot more
knows I have a boyfriend no no I just
got my heart broken no after getting to
know you maybe I have a boyfriend I'm
not mentally stable enough if a
[ __ ] tells you they're not
mentally stable enough to go on a date
with you
trust them
no no and we ended on a hot streak yeah
depends on which what car you drive I
drive a Lexus
okay we can work with that where are we
going uh I'll tell you where you want to
go McDonald's all right are you paying I
could pay for McDonald's
you require Alexis car but you want
McDonald's yeah I mean at least
I like going on dates with random people
you do this often no no like if they
come up to me and ask me like of course
I'm gonna say yes like if they had the
like the audacity to come up and ask me
and you look like my dad kind of
okay
hey you know what
some dudes want to get called daddy
what's the issue you know what I'm
saying yeah you're confident should we
all just go on a date together sure
trouble
oh minus number 97. if you were single
would you go on a date with me
now that leaves us with a 19 acceptance
rate that's it are you serious oh my I
knew I shouldn't have made this video I
knew I'd be too unlovable and no one
would love me like that and new girls
are too good for me
no Sam that's not true and I'm not just
saying that because I'm you if you look
at that number you're right 19 is pretty
bad but you have to remember that 63
said they weren't interested in dating
anyone right now not just you that means
you actually got 19 out of 37 interested
women to say yes that's over 50 and
these people they don't even know who
you are okay buddy I don't know if
you're watching right now if you are
I'm going to show you that most of those
women do not have boyfriends they were
not in relationships they just said that
because they wanted to get out of it and
I can also show you that 19 out of 100
is not a bad rate
in terms of acceptance It's actually
fantastic that's really good you got 19
out of the 100 people you ask out that's
amazing okay
what do I think when I watch this
a couple things one I think it's cool to
go out and put yourself out there two
for the people watching you have to
understand a few things one there's a
camera involved people who are on the
receiving end of that are going to act
different
right a lot of those interactions would
have gone South if it wasn't for this
camera project gimmick thing going on
secondly
just because you get a number doesn't
mean she going on the date one of the
second most difficult things is the
translation from getting the number to
getting the girl on a date and why
that's the most difficult part is that
if you didn't create any Intrigue off
the top they not even gonna respond to
your number when you text them plenty of
women will give you a fake number or
give you their number but never respond
because nothing was really there it's
kind of like when you're on online
dating and you're talking to a girl and
then that [ __ ] dies out even though
y'all match the reason why I died out is
because you didn't create any Intrigue
or even if you do grab her number from
Tinder if you don't get it excited or
interested she may never respond to your
texts that happens all the time
so this 19 number that he has is
probably like two or three
because most of these women were not
intrigued or interested they were not
enthusiastic about going on a date with
them they didn't even care like
uh yeah
maybe I guess
fine
when you get into like that that's not a
good thing like sure it's a good thing
that that they accept it and you put
yourself out there but it doesn't mean
you've translated that into an actual
date you know what I'm trying to say so
for anyone watching I'm just like
breaking it down a little bit for the
people
because you were asking me earlier I
think you asked me is that a good thing
or whatever so one other I'm like no
no that's why when you get the girl's
number you gotta do it in a way that's a
little bit of pizzazz that actually
piques her right so that when you get
her number you know like oh she's
definitely likely to respond
but if you just come up to like hey can
I get your number and she says yes
I guarantee you 95 of the time they
never gonna respond because they're like
so that's [ __ ] dude why would I be
interested in him you have to
demonstrated zero value
so that's just some of the more finer
parameters but I encourage people to go
do stuff try their shot shoot their shot
go up to these people approach them go
for it and it's cool to see folks doing
that I just wanted to give a bit more of
a realistic view of what it's actually
supposed to look like
what if you want to have better chances
of getting a date uh you could go on ta
Hanley th and Lee has some stuff for you
you can have a clearest kid not like my
buddy right there you can have a clear
skin I'm not violating it is what it is
bro you got to get a clear skin the
clear security is the first thing that
your [ __ ] is going to see when
they're going to see you you see hello
and they see pizza face I'm just saying
no all I'm saying is I could help you
just click on the link below go on Apple
and preach right and then right Albert
and preaching and you're going to be
able to have just get the pack number
like level one level one there's a scrub
to get all the nooks and crannies you
know that's why you get everything
you you probably pretty much sum it up
pretty good
there needs to be a background something
like when you're ready to do a cold call
like that it's there's nothing there's
no substance there's nothing even
sometimes when there's substance people
are not going to call you back because
but from the time that they say yes to
the time that you call them back there's
that lingering time where your
girlfriends talk to you whatever whatnot
you know deep ponder about how they feel
I don't know how I felt I don't know how
that God made me feel around this and
that and that [ __ ] decreases your
chances your chances doesn't increase
with time they decrease because they get
anxiety they start asking a bunch of
questions they start so
either you have to act quick or you have
to add substance to it
because it's going to decrease more time
that's what I I believe but yeah other
than that
at least you went out there
at least you went out there and you
asked like you you went out there most
[ __ ] I talked to you
I got a problem with a relationship yeah
what's up and you asked what's your
problem with relationships well I can't
get any relationship you know I can get
any girls to go out with cool did you
ask no
yep
at least he went out there and asked so
I gotta give him that